thank you Miss Barrymore for giving me
the floor you were a great opening act
hello Christopher yes Mitzi yeah yeah my
mother's uh has a dog named Mitzi
what's she named after you because she's
a big fan
first time doing this on television
I know usually it's in the comedy
Bargains and basements you know down
underneath at like one in the morning
what was your first time like
it's over very quickly
you know what's ironic this could be for
me too
now I thought that today I could try
some Impressions with you and you see if
you could guess them oh yeah great great
that sounds fun well here we go here's
the first one
[Laughter]
oh uh that seem oh that's the impression
yeah is it uh
is it uh Steve Martin snl2 wild and
crazy guys
[Music]
yes it is oh
oh okay here's the second
[Laughter]
oh the arm's up the arms up Rocky is it
Rocky hey
over two that's a very very good
Christopher all right Missy you you've
got a future here do you got any
impressions
um uh I've got one what if I asked you
to do like Brando eating a sandwich
because he's done that in bed with me
you know and I
it looks like so you know but nobody
else does because that's what he used to
do when he came into bed with me oh
before
during and after what do you think
Costanza got the bit for Seinfeld
okay uh
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that's it
that's it I didn't know I had one I
wanna thank you
you're bringing me back thank you for
that time machine
all right now you know like Brando you
know I heard sometimes you know you like
to gain a few and lose a few for a pot
it was very method that way what do you
like do you like you know a little love
handle one can pull on a do you like a
derriere that you can bounce a quarter
off of like an army bed
I don't do the quarters on the derriere
no
you run the card
that's how I that's how I get paid
[Applause]
something to think about later
oh well I have an award for you it's a
thing I do with people it's it's can you
get me to do a spit take oh
okay hold that thought
[Music]